we got a pair of teens on tick tock who
are going viral for this interesting
spring break story i dying to know what
you think about oh i'm so into this
story
new york post reports lydia and jaden
went on an all-inclusive vacation to
dominican republic it sounds fun right
but they did this a month after they
broke up
they said they said they were forced
into it when they found out the trip was
non-refundable they booked it before
they broke up then lydia tried to get it
transferred to her mom but when she
contacted the travel service they said
yeah no we we don't do that so
they tic-tock their entire trip
including the part where the hotel gave
them a room with just one bed in it
okay here's how bad do you need a
vacation if you're willing to go on with
an ex i mean i this actually makes total
sense to me like they could not get a
refund
and i actually think they totally did
the right thing by going on it do people
do not have money to waste i just think
this couple is cute and i love that they
posted about this and i feel like
there's people can relate to it and it's
just like oh you know what put it all
put all your baggage you know
not on the plane or even in the overhead
just don't bring it with you yeah just
go on the trip and have fun and maybe
maybe you know maybe
things might become illuminated but at
least you're leaving the vacation not
having wasted money and i just have to
say i think nancy meyers just found her
first movie
you're welcome right here
[Applause]
um okay next up we've got another
teenager making bold moves this story
comes from the week chloe campbell
started working at the coffee pot her
local coffee shop in duff town scotland
when she was just 15. and now four years
later she bought the place hey
that's right
chloe says her parents taught her to
save money so she saved and saved and
saved every check she made she saved and
then she mentioned to the owner that she
was thinking about running her own place
one day and then the owner said buy this
one and she did wow
congratulations chloe she's 19
and owns her own business
that's amazing
amazing
15 she started working when i was 15 i
worked at mcdonald's and then i worked
there for four years and you were the
triple threat i was a triple threat
register drive-through and grill and all
all i ever got was was transferred to
the mcdonald's express in the mall which
was like you know what i mean was that
how did that feel it wasn't great it
wasn't great and it's all cause steve
the manager and steve take the kick you
know who you are steve
you know where you are and you didn't
like me well
what's up steve
i worked in a coffee house too when i
was 14 um
and um my boss robert um he used to come
in you know with his cigarette lamb chop
listen darling the the delivery for the
muffins comes at 6 00 a.m honey not 6
p.m you're driving me crazy and i can't
fire you because i don't have the heart
oh you know i love robber
lamb chop and then you know that is
actually uh fun facts where i met my
sister and best friend cameron diaz i
was 14 at that coffee shop at that
coffee shop
she was a junior model she was 16. i was
14 and a barista and we made friends and
the story never ends and
we're still family so you know lamb chop
yeah you're killing me darling
so congratulations chloe it looks like
we're all doing all right
[Music]